as of guys my name is Anna welcome to
reaction Saturday today we're finally
getting to part two of my review slash
reaction of this road to PS 5 video
which I still have never seen the
remainder of just a quick recap if you
guys haven't seen part 1 check that out
because that was like the beginning of
this video we're starting from 14
minutes and 6 seconds into this video
which is exactly the same place as we
left off to summarize last video the
blazing fast SSD was like the biggest
thing we kind of talked about make sure
you check out that video so that you
know everything that is going on ok
let's jump in and take a look and as
always the video will be in the
description below and I mean we've still
got like 38 minutes or so left so I
don't know how much we'll get through so
let's just get into it
every little potential bottleneck needed
to be addressed and there are a lot of
them let's look at check-in and what
happens when it's overhead gets a
hundred times larger on apparently you
guys said that I stopped it like a
massive cliffhanger as soon as
everything gets really interesting which
of course I had no idea about because
I've never seen the video before so I'm
really excited for today's for today's
video
conceptually check-in is a pretty simple
process data is loaded into system
memory from the hard drive or SSD it's
examined a few values are tweaked to
check it in and then it's moved to its
final location at the SSD speeds we're
talking about that last part moving the
data meaning copying it from one
location to another takes roughly an
entire next-gen CPU core and that's just
the tip of the iceberg if all the
overheads get a hundred times larger
that will [ __ ] the frame rate as soon
as the player moves and that massive
stream of data starts coming off the SSD
so to solve all of that we built a lot
of custom hardware namely a custom flash
controller and a number of custom units
in our mainship I just want to say
quickly that um yeah I mean if it's not
already obvious the fact that graphics
are getting more detailed it doesn't
just mean that there's more processing
that has to be done by the GPU or by the
CPU it means that we have physically
more data on disk that we need to
somehow organize and deal with it's not
just all about lighting calculations and
like you know how many particles you
have in the screen or anything like that
it a lot of it has to do
the actual source of all of this data
unless it's like completely procedurally
generated which I'm sure a large chunk
of pretty much everything you see is
there are still cases where data needs
to obviously exist on the disk the flash
controller in the SSD was designed for
smooth and bottleneck free operation but
also with games in mind for example
there are six levels of priority when
reading from the SSD priority is very
important you can imagine the player
heading into some new location in the
world and the game requesting a few
gigabytes of textures and while those
textures are being loaded an enemy is
shot and has to speak a few dying words
having multiple priority levels like the
audio for those dying words get loaded
immediately on one side that flash
controller connects to the attack yeah I
mean what he's talking about is like
when you have a complex game and you
have so many things going on at any
point in time something could happen
that you didn't even expect because the
game is a game is an interactive piece
of software it's not just like a movie
that you're watching and you know
everything that's gonna happen what if
some event were to occur that suddenly
required so much other data to be loaded
that was completely unexpected that is
one of the things that was a really big
problem with like the PlayStation 4 and
below because as he's saying you know
you have to make sure to preload a lot
of a lot of what you're going to use
into RAM from the disk because you can't
just rely on randomly requiring a disk
read because it's too slow you're not
gonna be able to make it in time whereas
now especially because they'd not only
go to blazing processes day but all
these priority levels it's easy for
something something that was completely
unexpected to happen some event inside
the game and then you could just
transition to that news scene or new
like you know audio dialogue as he was
saying
I mean audio audio isn't like
particularly heavy to load usually but
the point is more unexpected things can
happen without requiring planning which
is really cool because it just makes
their game more dynamic actual flash
dies that supplies their back a little
bit on one side that flash controller
connects to the actual flash dies that
supply of the storage to reach our
bandwidth target of 5 gigabytes a second
we ended up with a 12 channel
face make channels wouldn't be enough
the resulting bandwidth we have achieved
is actually five-and-a-half gigabytes a
second with a 12 channel and that's this
gigabytes not Giga bits so that is
that's quite your face the most size
that emerges for an SSD is 825 gigabytes
the key question for us was is that
enough it's tempting to add more but
flash certainly doesn't come cheap and
we have a responsibility to our gaming
audience to be cost effective with
regards to what we put in the console
ultimately we resolve this question by
looking at the play patterns of a broad
range of gamers we examined the specific
games that they were playing over the
course of a weekend or week or a month
and whether that set of games would fit
properly on the SSD we were able to
establish that the friction caused by
reinstalled or read downloads would be
quite low and so we locked in on that
825 gigabyte size while also preparing
multiple strategies so that those who
want more storage can add it I'll go
through the details yeah that's good
because it's interesting like designing
a console is in many ways the way I see
like real-time graphics and a game
versus something like offline rendering
and like maybe a movie or something like
that when you're dealing with an offline
renderer you have a lot more leeway
because you don't necessarily have to
make sure that your frames are being
delivered in time like you can isn't
matter if it's like you know five hours
per frame or five-and-a-half hours per
frame or an extra minute like here and
they ultimately like of course you would
want to reduce the frame time as much as
possible still but it's not like a
real-time game where you'd literally
have to deliver if you're running at 60
frames per second you literally have to
deliver a frame in 16 milliseconds
otherwise it's gonna fall below that
frame rate it's it's it's an it's a very
interesting problem space and it's one
that I'm most interested in and it
results in a lot of kind of
approximations and it's just it's just a
challenging problem to solve and it
seems like this is also very similar
interestingly you know when you're
trying to build a console you can't just
get all the big components and then let
the audience just decide what they want
and do all of that like essentially they
have to come up with some kind of
package that is powerful but also
cost-effective so that a wide audience
can actually afford it and all
have the same experience as everyone
else on that particular platform which
is it's it's quite a challenge the other
thing that he said about the games kind
of how much room do we need how big
should the SSD be to accommodate all of
the games that someone might play within
a week handle so that's an interesting
way of putting it because obviously you
don't need to have your entire library
of games always on your SSD you can
always just uninstall games delete games
that you're not currently playing you
know your save files will probably be in
the cloud or something and then you can
you know download another game to play
this weekend that can obviously put a
lot of pressure on an internet
connection Internet is something that is
becoming more accessible and Ohio
bandwidth with every year so it is of
course a problem that is slowly kind of
going downhill but of course if you do
still live in an area that doesn't have
particularly good internet that can be a
problem but he did mention that you do
have the option to expand that storage
so if you live like far from a city and
maybe have a not-so-great internet
connection you probably opted into
buying some more hard drive or something
like that so that you can store your
games and not have to download them if
you suddenly decide oh I want to play
that game that I haven't played in a
couple months oh no it's gonna take a
day to download I'm also interested with
825 gigabytes how many games that's
gonna storm I guess is probably like
around eight or so I feel like these
games will probably be around a hundred
gigabytes age for like a big triple-a
title but I'm interested to see back to
the flash controller on the other side
it connects to our main custom chip via
four lanes of Gen 4 PCIe and inside the
main lanes is pretty hefty unit
dedicated to i/o before we talk about
what that does let's talk compression
for a moment PlayStation 4 used Z live
as it's compression formula we decided
to use it again on PlayStation 5 but on
my 2017 tour of developers I learned
about a new format called Kraken from
rad games yes that's Liv's smarter
cousin simple similar types of
algorithms but about 10% better
compression which is pretty big that
means 10% more game on the UHD blu-ray
disk or on the SSD Kraken had only been
out for a year that it was already
becoming a de-facto industry standard
half of the teams I talked to or either
using it or getting
to evaluate it so we hustled and built a
custom decompressor into the i/o unit
one capable of handling five gigabytes
of crack and format input data a second
Wow after decompression so see this is
what I'm talking about this is this is
the kind of advancement that I guess
consoles can have that pcs might not
generally be able to achieve because
what we're talking about here as far as
I can understand is custom hardware you
know it is literally doing decompression
in hardware it's not doing it on the CPU
from the GPU there is literally a unit
responsible for decompression of this
kraken format which is like zed lib but
a bit better inside the actual like ps5
like flash controller or whatever that
is really cool that's basically the
equivalent of buying like a red rocket
card or something for your computer so
that you can edit like red camera
footage a lot faster because you
literally have a PCIe card that is doing
that it's made to do the decompression
or whatever of that red footage that's
very similar to what this is it's like a
dedicated piece of hardware that does
the decompression which is going to be
faster than probably a CPU and GPU doing
it but also it's in addition to that so
the CPU and CPU can do other things
which is really cool and again part of
the reason why it's it might be possible
if they play their cards right to do
certain things on a PlayStation 5 that
would be slower to do on a computer and
I'm by no means saying that oh yeah
everyone should buy PS 5 because they're
better than pcs and you know that's not
absolutely not that they're different
pieces of hardware and I I appreciate
both sets of hardware because they're
both I think they're both cool just
relaxed flame walk that typically
becomes 8 or 9 gigabytes but the unit
itself is capable of outputting as much
as 22 gigabytes a second if the data
happened to compress particularly well
that's a lot by the way in terms of
performance that custom decompressor
equates to nine of ours and two cores
that's what it would take to decompress
the kraken stream with a conventional
cpu in the custom guy that that's a huge
that's that's a nice little unit that IO
unit including a dedicated DMA
controller the game can direct exactly
where
wants to send the data coming off of the
SSD this equates to another Xen two core
or two in terms of its copy performance
its primary purpose is to remove check
in as a bottleneck there's two dedicated
i/o coprocessors in a large ramp pool
these are tins in 2 cores there are
there principally to direct the variety
of custom hardware around them one of
the co processors is dedicated to SSD
i/o this lets us bypass traditional file
i/o and it's bottlenecks when reading
from the SSD the other is responsible
for memory mapping which I know doesn't
sound like anything related to the SSD
but a lot of developers map and remap
memory as part of file i/o and this -
that's very common memory mapping there
are memory mapping is basically treating
your disk as if it were RAM so you know
if you were like writing something in
C++ or in C or something you could
literally have like a pointer to a
particular memory location but that was
that memory location basically maps to a
file so behind the scenes is basically
just buffering the file in writing the
parts of it that you that you need but
it just simplifies kind of it simplifies
programming a lot and it means that you
don't have to deal with it means that
you can literally treat your disk as RAM
coherency engines to assist the
coprocessors coherency comes up a lot in
places probably the biggest coherency
issue is stale data in the GPU caches
flushing all of the GPU caches whenever
the SSD is read is an unattractive
option it could really hurt the GPU
performance so we've implemented a
gentler way of doing things where the
coherency engines inform the GPU of the
overwritten address ranges and custom
scrubbers in several dozen GPU caches to
pinpoint evictions of just those address
range that's the best thing as a game
developer when you read from the SSD you
don't need to know any of this you don't
even need to know so abstract is
compressed you just indicate what data
what you want to read from your original
uncompressed file and where you'd like
to put it and the whole process of
loading it happens invisibly to you and
at very high speed back to the dream
thanks to all of that surrounds our
dream our 5.5 gigabytes a second really
should translate into something like a
hundred times faster i/o than ps4 and
allow the dream of no load screens and
super fast streaming to become a reality
having said that expandability of our
SSD is going to be quite important
flash is costly and you may very well
want to add storage to whatever we put
in the college I was just I was just
thinking what happens though if you add
an external hard drive if it's not if it
doesn't have all these fancy features if
it doesn't have like you know all these
controllers and everything then it's
novice it not gonna be able to perform
as well now the kind of storage you need
depends on how you're going to use if
you have an extensive PlayStation 4
library and you'd like to take advantage
of back I imagine you could just like
swap the you could probably swap your
games if you had enough free disk space
probably just swap your games between
external and PS 5 SSD especially if you
had a game that really required the
ssstay to be blazing fast its
compatibility to play those games on
PlayStation 5 than a large external hard
drive is ideal you can leave your games
on the hard drive and play them directly
from there thus saving the pricier SSD
storage for your PlayStation 5 titles or
you can copy your active PlayStation 4
titles to the SSD if your purpose in
adding more storage is to play
playstation 5 titles though ideally you
would add to your SSD storage we will be
supporting certain m2 SSDs these are
internal drives that you can get on the
open market and install in a bay in the
playstation 5 as for moments we do same
and when I'll get to that in a moment
they connect and well he's probably
about explains the custom io unit just
like it our SSD does so they can take
full advantage of the decompression IO
coprocessors okay all the other features
that's all shared so that they managed
to separate the actual storage component
of it and he's saying that m2 SSDs can
be used which are pretty popular a lot
of people use them now in the net PC
builds because they're just that they're
extremely fast acestes that connect
right into the motherboard via Lex PCIe
and the cool thing here is that all of
the like the big compression you and all
of that
that's not actually part of like it's
not enclosed inside their custom SSD it
seems to be separated which means that
the actual backing storage for all of
that fanciness that is that can be like
swapped to anything else which is
obviously ideal because it means that
you can expand your storage and you
don't need to do what I just said which
was like copying your game into like
from your external hard drive or I mean
if you have an SSD external as the state
into the PS 5 as the state because that
you really requires that speed it should
just work which is pretty cool here's
the catch though that drive has to be at
least as fast as ours well your games
that rely on the speed of our SSD need
to make synonymously with nem to drive
when I gave the Wired interview last
year I said that the PlayStation 5 SSD
was faster than anything available on PC
at the time commercial em 2 drives used
pcie 3.0 and four lanes of that cap out
at 3.5 gigabytes a second yeah in other
words no PCIe I I didn't I didn't
remember these numbers off the top of my
head but five and a half oh five and a
half gigabytes a second did seem very
high to me 3.0 Drive can hit the
required spec M two drives with PCI u
4.0 or now out in the market we're
getting our in samples and seeing four
or five gigabytes a second from them
five years and I expect there will be
drives that saturate 4.0 and support
seven gigabytes a second having said
that we are comparing apples and oranges
though because that commercial m2 Drive
will happen bet that photo on the right
is an m2 Drive and finest SSD being on
the left o flash controller and so on
for example the nvme specification lays
out a priority scheme for requests that
the m2 drives can use and that scheme is
pretty nice but it only has two true
priority levels our drive support 6 yeah
ok so do look up the drive with only two
priority levels definitely but our
custom i/o unit has to arbitrate the
extra priorities rather than the m2
drives flash controller and so the m2
Drive needs a little extra speed to take
care of issues arising no different
approach that Commercial Drive also
needs to physically the PS 5s is days
specifically specialized with custom
things and so I guess it is a bit of a
hybrid it's not just plug and play with
an external SSD it still does have
certain things that are built into it
like those priority levels that you
can't really achieve with some kind of
just a random like third-party m2 SSD so
to counter the fact that it doesn't have
those priority levels and that their
controllers need to basically emulate
those priority levels it has to be even
faster to kind of accommodate that
inside of the bay we created in
PlayStation 5 for m2 drives unlike
internal hard drives there's
unfortunately no standard for the height
of an m2 drive and some M true drives
have giant heat sinks in fact some of
them even have their own fans Wow right
now we're getting em to drive samples
and benchmarking them in various ways
when games hit beta as they get ready
for the PlayStation 5 launch at year-end
we'll also be doing some compatibility
testing to make sure that the
architecture of particular M 2 drives
isn't too foreign for the games to
handle once we've done that
compatibility testing we should be able
to start letting you know which drives
will physically fit and which drive
samples have benchmark appropriately
high in our testing it would be great if
that happened by launch but it's likely
to be a bit past it so please hold off
on getting that M to drive until you
hear from us ok back to our principles
balancing evolution and revolution is
the second of them
this was definitely a recurring theme
with the GPU we need new GPU features
and capabilities if if we only have more
performance it's not really a new
generation of console of course many of
these capabilities result in more
performance that's part of why a
Playstation 5 teraflop is more powerful
than a PlayStation 4 teraflop but we
aren't just looking for the performance
we also need the ability to do something
with the GPU that could not have been
done before and we need higher
performance per watt
every time we double the performance of
some GPU component we don't want to find
out we've doubled the power consumed and
the heat produced but at the same time
we have to make sure the GPU can run ps4
games and we have to ensure that the
Oh texture is easy for the developers to
adopt now backwards-compatibility the
simple master of deleting sensitive they
treated it as a key need throughout the
design process as our solution to adding
new features without blindsiding
developers we made sure that if there
were new significant features it would
be optional to use them the GPU supports
ray tracing but you don't have to use
ray tracing to make your game the GPU
supports primitive shaders but you can
release your first game on PlayStation 5
without making any use of them before I
get into the capabilities of the GPU I'd
like to that's always good giving
developers flexibility into how they
actually make their games instead of
forcing them into a particular pipeline
is always a good thing and they clear
two points that can be quite confusing
first we have a custom AMD GPU based on
there are DNA 2 technology what does
that mean AMD is continuously improving
and revising their tech for our DNA to
their goals were roughly speaking to
reduce power of consumption by we
architecting the GPU to put data close
to where it's needed
to optimize the GPU for performance and
to adding new more advanced feature set
but that feature set is malleable which
is to say that we have our own needs for
PlayStation and that can factor into
what the AMD roadmap becomes so
collaboration is born if we bring
concepts to AMD that are felt to be
widely useful then they can be adopted
into our DNA too and used broadly
including in PC GPUs if the ideas are
sufficiently specific to what we're
trying to accomplish
like the GPU cache scrubbers I was
talking about then they end up being
just for us if you see a similar
discrete GPU available as a PC card at
roughly the same time as we release our
console that means our collaboration
with AMD
succeeded in producing technology useful
in both worlds it doesn't mean that we
as sony simply incorporated the pc part
into our console this continuous
improvement in AMD technology means it's
dangerous to rely on teraflops as an
absolute indicator it that's never a
good indicator I really hate it when
people get obsessed
with teraflops what on earth that's like
being like oh my my CPU is three and a
half gigahertz that means nothing CPUs
20 years ago 15 years ago a Pentium 4
can be three and a half Giga don't tell
me that's as good as like an i7 or
something in 2020 a performance and see
you count should be avoided as well in
the case of CPU as we all in it's like
being like my camera is 20 megapixels
yeah men rock on Stan this the
PlayStation 4 and PlayStation 5 each
have eight CPUs but we never think that
meant the capabilities and performance
are equal it's the same for C use for
one thing they've been getting much
larger over time adding new features
means adding lots of transistors in fact
the transistor count for a Playstation
5cu is 62% larger than the transistor
count for a Playstation 4 CU second the
playstation 5 and GPU is backwards
compatible with playstation 4 what does
that mean one way you can achieve
backwards compatibility I'm glad they
stopped keeping the relatives at in the
new console like we did with some
PlayStation 3s but that's of course
extremely expensive yeah a better way is
appropriate any differences in the
previous consoles logic into the new
consoles custom chips meaning that even
as the technology evolves the logic and
feature set that PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 4 Pro titles rely on is
still available in backwards
compatibility modes one advantage of
this strategy is that once backwards
compatibility is in the console it's in
if not as if a cost down will remove
backwards compatibility like it did on
PlayStation 3 achieving this unification
of functionality took years of efforts
by AMD as any roadmap advancement
creates a potential divergence in logic
I just want to point out that this is
this is like one of the most frustrating
things that developers and engineers
have to deal with if this whole
backwards compatibility thing because
obviously when you discover when you do
research and you discover ways to
drastically improve existing
technologies you want to adopt that as
soon as possible and just
basically move the world forward but but
instead of doing that you have to make
sure that your backwards compatible you
have to make sure that everything that
used to work still works and there are
certain companies that are excellent and
maintaining backwards compatibility
instead of companies that might not be
as good and I just wanted to share that
like this is frustrating and it honestly
makes everything I would say like twice
as hard because not that they they can't
focus on this new exciting technology
they can just use they have to make sure
they make it work in a way with the old
stuff and on one hand obviously I feel
like that is holding them back maybe not
in final result but definitely in
development time and where they actually
need to spend that time but it's
unfortunately necessary to make sure
that players can play older titles so
running yeah ps4 and PS 4 titles at
boosted frequencies has also added
complexity the boost is truly massive
this time around and some game code just
can't handle it testing has on the title
by title basis results are excellent
though we recently took a look at the
top hundred PlayStation 4 titles as
ranked by play time and we're expecting
almost all of them to be playable at
launch on PlayStation 5 hmm with regards
to new features as I said our strategy
was to try to break new ground but at
the same time not to require use of the
new GPU capabilities for more than a
decade GPUs have imposed a restriction
on game engines software handles vertex
processing but for the most part
dedicated hardware is responsible for
the triangles and other geometry that
the vertices form that means it's not
possible to do even basic optimizations
such as aborting processing of a vertex
if all geometry that uses it is off
screen PlayStation 5 has a new unit
called the geometry engine which brings
handling of triangles and other
primitives under full programmatic
control you know as a game developer
your this is probably similar like a
mesh shader in DirectX 12 ultimate you
ignore its existence and use the
PlayStation 5 and GPU as if it were no
more capable than the ps4 GPU or you can
use this new intelligence in various
ways
simple usage could be performance
optimizations such as removing back
faced or off-screen vertices and
triangles more complex usage involves
something called primitive shaders which
allow the game to synthesize geometry on
the fly
as it's being rendered it's abuse this
is probably what Unreal Engine 5 was
using to do all of that like triangle
decimation stuff new capability using
primitive shaders on PlayStation 5 will
allow for a broad variety of techniques
including smoothly varying level of
detail addition of procedural detail to
close up objects and improvements to
particle effects and other visual
special effects this is great these new
shaders I know a little bit about like
DirectX 12 ultimate like the stuff that
they've kind of added in the form of
mesh shaders and all that kind of stuff
but this this stuff is to me very
exciting the fact that the GPU can do
all of this stuff now and you can
essentially leave the GPU things up to
the GPU and kind of relax the CPU a
little bit I think this is really cool
and I think this is gonna make a big
difference in the next generation
another major new feature of our custom
our DNA - based GPU is ray tracing using
the same strategy as AMD's upcoming PC
GPUs the ciues contain a new specialized
unit called the intersection engine
which can calculate the intersection of
rays with boxes and triangles to use the
intersection engine first you build what
is called an acceleration structure this
is this is very this is this is just the
standard right tracing and pretty much
it's been in it's been supported by dart
x12 and welcome for quite some time with
like then video on TX stuff and
everything's data in RAM pretty much the
same all of your geometry there's a
specific set of formats you can use
there variations on the same BVH concept
then in your shader program you use a
new instruction that asks the
intersection engine to check array
against the BVH yeah well the
intersection is regular ray tracing the
requested ray triangle or ray box
intersections the shaders are free to do
other work having said that the ray
tracing instruction is pretty memory
intensive so it's a good mix with logic
heavy code there's of course no need to
use ray tracing ps4 graphics engines
will
run just fine on PlayStation 5 but it
presents an opportunity for those
interested I'm thinking it'll take less
than a million rays a second to have a
big impact on audio that should be
enough for audio occlusion and some
reverb calculations with a bit more of
the GPU invested in ray-tracing
it should be possible to do some very
nice global illumination
having said that adding ray-traced
shadows and reflections to a traditional
graphics engine could easily take
hundreds of millions of rays a second
and full ray tracing could take billions
how far can we go I'm starting to get
quite bullish I've already seen a
PlayStation 5 title that's successfully
using ray tracing based reflections in
complex animated scenes with only modest
costs another set of issues and and
obviously like the denoising algorithms
at play yeah I haven't looked into them
probably in the last year or so but if
denoising algorithms get better than
that can drastically reduce how many
Ray's you actually have to shoot and it
basically just means that everything
will be cheaper meaning it will take
less performance to actually achieve
Depew so this is something that will
likely evolved over the course of the
ps5 lifecycle as well alt size and
frequency how big do we make the GPU and
what frequency do we run it at this is a
balancing act the chip has a cost and
there's a cost for whatever we use to
supply that chip with power and to cool
it in general I like running the GPU at
a higher frequency let me show you why
here's two possible configurations for a
GPU roughly of the level of the
PlayStation 4 Pro this is a thought
experiment don't take these
configurations too seriously
if you just calculate teraflops you get
the same number but actually the
performance is noticeably different
because teraflops is defined as the
computational capability of the vector
ALU that's just one part of the GPU
there are a lot of other units and those
other units all run faster when the GPU
frequency is higher at 33% higher
frequency rasterization goes 33% faster
processing the command buffer goes that
much faster the l2 and other caches have
that much higher bandwidth and
about the only downside is that system
memory is 33% further away in terms of
cycles but the large number of benefits
more than counterbalance then as a
friend of mine says a rising tide lifts
all boats also it's easier to fully use
36c use in parallel than it is to fully
use 48c use when triangles are small
it's much harder to fill although see
use with useful work so it's the same as
like getting if you buy like a thread
ripper like a cpu that has I don't know
like 36 or 64 or whatever on earth
they're up to cause it's very different
it's quite difficult for software to
leverage all of those cores like maybe
if you have like some kind of offline
renderer and it literally is just doing
all of that stuff on the CPU which you
might you might do then maybe you can
fill that but in general you know just
because you add more and more like
parallel processing it doesn't
necessarily mean that you'll be able to
use all of that
now GPUs a massive parallel processing
units and that's for a specific reason
but in general it in a lot of cases it
can really help to actually improve your
base kind of per core clock speed and
and all of that kind of technology
rather than just trying to you know add
more and more cause there's a lot to be
said for faster assuming you can handle
the resulting power and heat issues
which frankly we haven't always done the
best job part of the reason for that is
historic ok we're gonna get into power
consumption next time gonna pause it
here we're at 33 minutes and 20 seconds
there's gonna be one final part to me
kind of reacting to this I'm just gonna
try and finish it next time I hope you
guys enjoyed this video please hit a
like button if you did and if you're new
don't forget to subscribe don't worry
I'm not gonna make you wait a week for
the next part I'll try and put it up in
the next couple days or so until then
though I will see you next time goodbye
[Music]